let's talk about number seven which is
mainstream media and then we'll and then
we'll take some call-ins um i'll i'll
let you guys talk about mainstream media
while i drop the link there in the live
chat okay um this is i think what i had
mentioned to a couple of you guys the
the other night um i went over to my
friend's house and those of you in the
community who have been around my house
and come into my house notice i don't
have a tv on the main floor of my house
and they'd be like where's your tv i
said it's down in the basement think of
a show you want to watch and we'll go
watch it later so i call her onto my
friend's house and he's got the big
80-inch tv in his new you know gigantic
house
and girl i was with me and her looked at
each other after 20 minutes because the
mainstream media television was on i
said my head's about to explode are you
the same she said yeah i can't handle
this it's just all doomed loom drama and
driving your stress level through the
roof and this is what most people
consume every single day of the week and
i'll guarantee you there's people
watching this stream now rich and they
got their tv on and they got their phone
in their other hand and they're trying
to consume multimedia all at the same
time and if you consume mainstream media
on a regular basis you will end up in a
perma rage i'm convinced of it
well i mean look what the mainstream
media did for the last two years that
convinced the entire world
that a common cold was a pandemic
actually and banked on it too made
yeah the other side of the equation
right it's like you got to think about
what their end product is right because
the thing that i get into this debate
with some of my friends right where
especially over the last like five to
ten years right we had some debates and
i always bring up the point of you gotta
remember like news is a manufactured
product just like everything else it's
not pure it's not like oh this just
falls from the sky here's the story is
it amazing you know it's it's
manufactured so you have to sell it to
that light and see it in that context
and you got to see all right what's
their number one product that they're
selling right right now currently in
this world it's it's fear right i mean
if you were to watch an hour of news you
would be convinced that everyone in
america runs around yelling racial slurs
at each other shooting each other with
guns
24 7. that's exactly the world that they
portray versus you go outside like oh
the birds are still chirping the sky is
still blue the sun's still rising you go
out people are genuinely friendly so you
know that's the
really difficult thing for people to
understand is like understand one what
they're trying to sell you but two
understand
they have
a motivation and a reason for what
they're presenting to you and it's not
in your best interest it does not serve
you
everybody's selling you something i mean
i talked about well like i try to i even
try to watch multiple news sources to be
as
unbiased as possible like they're all
trying to sell you something like turn
it if you want to be if you want to get
from an unbiased view turn off your
television and even to rw's point like i
live in new york city and
you every day the news
is about robberies shootings
assaults etc and yet the crime rate has
plummeted in this city over the last
40 years steadily year over year it's
like at an all-time low but you wouldn't
know that just by watching five minutes
of tv i mean it's just it's they are
selling sensationalism because
sensationalism gets clicks which gets
sells ad space which puts more money in
their pockets follow the money man gets
people elected it's entertainment it's
not news yeah there was a um
a tweet that i retweeted out earlier
today and when i talk about mainstream
media then i'm also talking about
politicians too politics government
and
this one here was profound man it says
uh when a politician tells you something
ask yourself what does he stand to gain
if i believe what he's saying
yeah exactly and if you approach every
joe biden speech justin trudeau
whoever minister of foreign dippity [ __ ]
blueberry blah you know starts opening
their mouth and the words tumble out ask
yourself that question what does this
dude what does this chick stand to gain
if i believe what they're telling me
well it's also like does it serve me
and it's also become so politicized like
one of the large reasons why i've
stopped like watching sports a lot is
because now more modern athletes they
can't just be athletes they have to be
athletes activists right there's always
some cause or some moral lecture that we
have to get on top of trying to enjoy
the spirit of competition so it's not
enough that like oh you can't just you
know sit back for two hours and like be
entertained it's now constant where okay
you know you always have to be reminded
like hey like this is this is bad or
don't do this or don't do that right or
we're trying to tell you or sell you on
something and it's like yeah it's just
we're just trying to enjoy life here
they make 20 million dollars a year and
they consider themselves victims so that
means they're idiots and then also as
the viewer you're the consumer you're
their audience and any company that
insults their customer does not deserve
my business that's kind of how i see it
because i love the nfl but i can't it's
unwatchable right now it's a bunch of
crybabies i dude i haven't bought
gillette razor blades right there you
know for that reason a couple years ago
they'll never see a dime out of my
pocket again they can suck it
but um
can i talk to paul about the human
psychology aspect of fear because uh
absolutely
humans are built to pay attention to
fear if ancient man walked out of a cave
and he's like oh there's a saber-toothed
tiger he's cute let me go over here and
get an apple okay we wouldn't be here
so funny
yeah plenty did yeah debaters and i'm
getting a soy over here well there's a
bit saber to the tiger there but
um
so
this is why news sells fear all day long
and the weather channel if you turn on
the weather channel you'll be convinced
there's a tornado two blocks down the
street
and yeah this this l figure so you will
pay attention and that's all i want is
you paying attention once you figure
that out once you figure out the matrix
that this thing on my wall is trying to
scare me and fill me with blue pill
stuff and just to circle back to
something like jen sackey from something
else the marriage industry in the us is
a 57 billion a year industry and if you
don't think they're putting a message
out to plug you into
uh giving them some of that money then
plugged in the um the whole uh
diamond thing you know the um engagement
three month salary yeah like you know
the story i started with like you know
the marketing team was like well let's
tell guys you know to uh spend three
months of their salary on a diamond ring
and then they were so shocked that that
worked so [ __ ] well back in the day
they're like you know what [ __ ] it let's
tell these idiots six months now and
like guys spent more money right it's
like
there's there's no critical thinking
anymore it's like we have entire
holidays for marketing sweetest day was
made so that the chocolate companies
could get a boost in revenue so they
literally made up a day
and it's still being
practiced today you know like
yeah
you know
you know to spot my house on st
patrick's day it's the only house that's
not covered in green crap
this is a drink too like most holidays
are excuses to drink
yeah and over and over indulge and
behave in blue pill lifestyle that's it
once i i think you reached peak
unplugging when you just start noticing
every holiday as a bunch of trash
marketing for people and it's literally
you can spot the plugged in people in
your neighborhood in your society they
change what their house looks like every
holiday and it's become more and more
holidays like you would think if you
were an alien and you dropped into this
planet you would think cinco de mayo was
a holiday for drunken white chicks you
would not know it has anything to do
with mexico
have a theory about this this is a
little bit off talk topic but i have a
theory about this i mean
i started to notice this you know just
around the holiday times where you see
people spend a lot of money and time you
know for example like around christmas
you know decking out their houses with
lights and icicles and like all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] light shows going to music
with disco balls and laser beams and all
this [ __ ] and like when you take a look
at them and you know the couples
you start to realize something these
people aren't [ __ ]
that's why they have all this time to do
all this [ __ ] like all these guys in the
panel right now we don't put up all this
[ __ ] around christmas time i don't
even have i haven't had a christmas tree
in like a decade like since i left home
i've never had one like if a girl brings
a little baby one like like cats
like run out to the store and like you
know suck back those blue pills and plug
in the lies and get all this [ __ ] and
get that [ __ ] and hang it up and you
know like a week later you have to take
it down
holidays are times to travel for me yeah
like that back when it's on the salary
days going back to that have somebody
else every day if you like the way it
looks hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you